in your experience does their
distinction between administrators and
faculty in terms of uh perpetrators of
this of these kinds of things so if if
we got rid of all like Harvey's talked
about uh getting rid of a large
percentage of the administration does
that help fix the problem or is the
faculty also yeah small
percent of the faculty also part of the
encouraging in the organization of these
kind of cancel yeah and and that's
something that has been profoundly
disappointing um is that when you look
at the huge uptick in attempts to get
professors fired that we've seen over
the last 10 years
and actually over the last 22 years as
far back as our records go
um
at first they're overwhelmingly led by
administrators attempts to get
professors punished
um and that was most you know I'd say
that was my career up until 2013 was was
fighting back at administrative excesses
um then you start having the problem in
2014 of students trying to get people
canceled and that really accelerated in
2017. and the number so one way that one
one thing that makes it easier to
document is are the petitions to get
professors fired or punished
um and how disproportionately that those
actually do come from students but
another big uptick has been fellow
professors demanding that their fellow
professors get punished and that to me
can be really sad it's kind of shameful
you you shouldn't be proud of signing
the petition to get your fellow
professor and what's what's even more
more shameful is that we get store this
this is a this has almost become a
cliche within fire when someone is
facing one of these cancellation
campaigns as a professor I would get
letters from some of my friends saying I
am so sorry this has happened to you
and these were the same people who
publicly signed the petition to get them
fired yeah yeah
integrity
Integrity is an important thing in this
world and I think some of it
I'm so surprised people don't stand up
more for this because there's so much
hunger for it and if you have the guts
as a faculty or an administrator to
really stand stand up
uh with eloquence
with rigor with Integrity I feel like
it's impossible for anyone to do
anything because there's such a hunger
it's so refreshing yeah I think
everybody agrees that freedom of speech
is a good thing oh I don't I don't well
okay sorry I don't agree the majority of
people even at the universities that
there's a hunger but it's almost like uh
this kind of nervousness around it
because there's a small number of loud
voices yeah they're doing the shouting
so I mean again that's where great
leadership comes in and so you know
presence of University should probably
be making clear Declarations of like
this is not this is a place where we
value the freedom of expression when and
this was oh this all throughout my
career
um a president a university president
who puts their foot down early and says
Nope you know we are not entertaining
firing this professor we are not
expelling the student it ends the issue
often very fast although sometimes and
this is where you can really tell the
administrative involvement students will
do things like take over the president's
office and then that takeover will be
catered by the university people will
point this out sometimes as being kind
of like oh it's clearly like um my
friend Sam Abrams when they tried to get
uh tried to get him fired at a Sarah
Lawrence College
um and uh that was one of the times that
that it was used as kind of like oh this
was hostile to the university because
they the students took over the
president's office and I'm like no they
let them take over the president's
office and I don't know if that was one
of the cases in which the the Takeover
was catered but if there was ever sort
of like a sign that's kind of like yes
this isn't this is actually really quite
friendly